[Music]
well good evening London two weeks ago
Sam Harris and Jordan Peterson met in
person for the first time on stage in
Vancouver
two nights ago the three of us got
together for the first time in Dublin
and it's a huge thrill for all of us to
now be here with you in the o2
[Applause]
as I said to Travis when these events
were planned
I'm not moderate enough to be a
moderator but I'm going to do a little
bit of fielding to begin with
so let me start by saying a little of
some of the ground we are going to be
trying to cover here tonight we're going
to be dealing with the conflict between
science and reason we're going to be
addressing the legitimacy did I say
science and reason we're not addressing
that we're going to be looking at the
legitimacy of holding on to religion in
any form and we are also going to be
addressing the fact that we need to hide
in a sports stadium to address serious
issues but I think to begin with I'm
going to hand over to Sam and he's going
to kick us off properly thank you and
first thank you all for coming out I you
really can't imagine how humbling this
is be here with you
you really just should just take a
moment to appreciate this from our side
because Justin Bieber is not coming out
to sing and in the middle of this as
amusing as that would be and you know
though we put a date like this on the
calendar with apparent confidence
there's really no guarantee that you
guys are going to show up and we will
never take this for granted so it's
really an immense privilege to be here
with you so I thought I could start by
first acknowledging how fun this has
been to have this these series of
dialogues with Jordan now this is the
fourth event we've done and the second
with Douglas and we clearly share a
common project we are trying to figure
out how to live the best lives possible
both individually and collectively and
we're trying to figure out how to build
societies that safeguard that
opportunity for as many people as
possible and I think we each have a
sense that ideas are really the prime
movers here that is it's not that the
world is filled with bad people doing
bad things because that's what bad
people do oh there's some of that it it
is mostly that so much of humanity is
living under the sway of bad ideas and
it's bad ideas that can cause good
people or at least totally normal people
like ourselves to do bad things all the
while trying to to live the best
possible lives and that really is the
tragedy of our circumstance that we can
be that confused so this is where the
difference between Jordan and and me in
particular opens up which is how do you
view religion in this in this contest of
between good ideas and bad ideas and for
me religion emphatically
gets placed on the side of bad and old
and and worth retiring ideas or ideas
worth retiring and I guess I
but by analogy I would I would ask you
to consider astrology right now Hannah
maybe I can just get a sense of what I'm
talking to what percentage of you I want
to know believe in astrology which is to
say but who among you and you can signal
this by by applause or howls of
enthusiasm what what percentage of you
let me just spell it out so I know you
know what you're committing to and you
know how crazy your neighbor is in fact
what percentage do you believe that
human personalities and human events and
the difference between good and bad luck
and a human life is the result of what
the planets are doing against the
background of stars let's hear it
somebody out there okay so then you
should know that something like 25% of
your your neighbors believe that there
you go so the I'm here wait wait wait
I'm hearing I'm hearing a heckler among
the astrologers is that is the FIR the
first astrological heckler I've heard
haha you must be an aries sir
[Applause]
so it won't surprise you I have a
related question which is what what
percentage of you I want to know our
religious which is say well who among
you believe in God a personal God a God
that can hear prayers a God that can
take an interest in the lives of human
beings and occasionally enforce good
outcomes versus bad outcomes
what who among you and now again I want
to hear applause or silence believe in
it that sort of God okay so this is my
concern is my concern with with what
Jordan has been saying and right in lo
these many months I feel that you're in
danger of misleading these the second
group of people that the way you talk
about God has convinced and will
continue to convince some percentage of
humanity that it's it's fine to hold on
to this old sword of God this God that
can hear prayers and they can intervene
or not in the lives of human beings and
you know as we've begun to explore that
I think there are a lot of problems with
that kind of belief if nothing else
there are many such gods on offer and
there and and devotion to them it
becomes irreconcilable among the true
believers and my concern is it you could
do exactly what you do with religion
with astrology right it would be it
would be no more legitimate to to
obfuscate the boundary between clear
thinking and and superstition there
because the this traditional God and the
and the doctrines that support him or
are no firmer ground than astrology is
now today an astrology almost everything
you say about religion it's the fact
that his organized human thinking for
thousands of years that it's a cultural
Universal that every every group of
people has has given rise to some form
of it that it has archetypal
significance that it
has powerful stories all of that can be
said about astrology and it and in fact
some additional things can be said about
astrology that are would argue in its
favor for instance astrology is
profoundly egalitarian you know there's
there's no bad zodiac sign every whoever
you are everyone's got a great zodiac
sign and you know it's just a
inconvenient fact of the discipline that
if I read you Charles Manson's horoscope
you know 95% of the audience would find
it relevant and and that's just that's
how easily falsifiable stralla g is but
my concern is that we could live in a
world where societies are shattered over
things like you know different zodiac
interpretations and we don't live in
that world for good reason because we
have beaten astrology into submission
and I would say that religion in terms
of revealed religion and belief in a
personal God is over the centuries
getting the same treatment by science
and rationality and should be and it is
a a preferred circumstance that we live
in a world that is that is shattered by
religion
[Applause]
so I think what I'll do first is adopt
the exceptionally difficult and likely
counterproductive position of saying
something not so much in defense of
religion but in defense of astrology
knowing knowing full well that that's
fundamentally a fool's errand but
there's something I want to point out is
that first of all astrology was
astronomy in its nascent form and
astrology was also science in its
nascent form just like alchemy was
chemistry in its nascent form and so
sometimes you have to dream a crazy
dream with all of the error that that
crazy dream entails because you have an
intuition that there's something there
to motivate you to develop the intuition
to the point where it actually becomes
of genuine practical utility now when we
look back on the astrologers and we view
their contributions to the history of
the world with contempt we should also
remember that the people who built
Stonehenge for example and the first
people who decided determined that our
fates were in part written in the stars
were people whose astrological beliefs
were indistinguishable from their
astronomical beliefs and you might think
well in what sense is your fate written
in the Stars and I would say it's
certainly the case insofar as there are
such things as cosmic regularities so it
was the dream of astrology that there
was some relationship between the
movement of the planetary bodies and the
fixed stars and human destiny and that's
what drove us to build the first
astronomical observatories and to also
determine that there was a proper time
for planting and a proper time for
harvesting and a way of orienting
yourself in the world for example by
using the north
it's also the poetic ground that enabled
us to identify the notion that you could
look up and orient yourself towards the
heavens and that there was a
metaphorical relationship between that
and positioning yourself properly in
life and at a deeper level the the the
cosmos was the place that the human
imaginative drama was externalized and
draped itself out into the world as
something that was essentially
observable so that we could derive great
orienting fictions from the observation
of our imagination and so part of the
problem that that Sam is pointing to is
the difficulty of distinguishing valid
poetic impulse from invalid poetic
impulse and that really is a tremendous
problem you you see that arise also in
people who have religious delusions
attendant upon manic depressive disorder
or schizophrenia but so much of what
eventually manifests itself is hard core
pragmatic scientific belief has its
origin in wild flights of poetic fantasy
and it's also the case by the way that
that's actually how your brain is
organized as far as I can tell that when
you and and it isn't just me I actually
it's it's there's a very large what
would you call it research literature
outlining the relative functions of the
right and left hemisphere and it
certainly appears to be the case that
when we encounter something absolutely
unknowable or unknown what we do is
drape that unknown thing in fantasy as a
first pass approximation to the truth
and then refine that fantasy as a
consequence of iterative critical
analysis and so Sam believes that what
should happen is that the the poetic and
fictional domain should be some planted
by the rational domain well let me just
close the loop there it's not quite I
think we we need poetry and fiction and
then there's there's more to engage in
with reality than being a scientist in a
white lab coat but we need to be able to
clearly distinguish fact from fantasy or
fact from mere merely fertile flights of
the imagination
and we want to be rigorous there and
rational there and it's not that it's
not that there's no place or mere
creativity that's not well I guess well
then the rails of rationality look fair
enough then but I mean then then partly
what we are disputing is the the
relevant the what the relative import
and the of those two domains let's say
the heretic and the fictional and the
rational and status of religion now in
that well I have a hard time reconciling
that to some degree with your with your
more what would you say
formal statements about the problem
because your mechanism the mechanism
that you put forth above all outside of
truth is rationality and it isn't clear
to me if you're willing to allow the
utility of spiritual experience which
you do and and and if you're willing to
make what would you say allowances for
the necessity of the poetic imagination
exactly how it is that that is also
encapsulated under the rubric of pure
rationality see let's see and here's
something you can tell me what you think
about this and I've been thinking a lot
about what Sam and I have been talking
about by the way you know so I'm making
the case in my writing that the
democratic institutions not only grew
out of the judeo-christian substrate but
that their that that they're properly
ensconced within that substrate but I'm
also perfectly aware that not every
religious or poetic system gives rise to
democratic institutions first and also
that there are Christian sub structures
may be the most obviously in the case of
the Russian Orthodox Church where the
same metaphysical principles apply but
out of which a democracy did not emerge
and so it does seem to me that what we
have in the West is the consequence of
the interplay between the fantasy
predicated poetic judeo-christian
tradition and the rational critique that
was aimed at that by the Enlightenment
figures and that seems to me to mirror
something like the proper balance
between the right hemisphere and its
poetic imagination and the
left hemisphere and it's critical
capacity and then I would say that part
of the way so one of the questions you
brought up was how do we decide which
let's say religious in intuitions are
valid and I think we do that in part
through negotiated agreement you know
because people have look even even among
the Catholics say in the medieval time
there was an absolute horror of heresy
so if you were some mendicant monk and
you had a profound religious vision the
probability that you were going to be
tried as a heretic and burnt at the
stake was extremely high because even
the gatekeepers of the religious
tradition realized that religious
revelation untrammeled by something like
community dialogue something like that
was something extraordinary danger and
so I would agree with you that the
poetic imagination and the ground of
religious revelation is something that
can lead people dangerously astray but I
would say at the same time that it
constitutes the grounds of our initial
exploration and that it's actually in a
radically necessary
okay well briefly address that and I
want to ask a question that brings
Douglas directly in here I I think this
is an instance of what's called the
genetic fallacy the idea that because
something emerged the way it did
historically as a matter of historical
contingency it is the the the the origin
is in fact good and worth maintaining or
that it was in fact necessary that we
couldn't get these good things like
democracy any other way or were unlikely
to and I would say that that there's no
Abrahamic religion that is the best
conceivable womb of democracy or
anything else we like science that were
a great place to get Douglass involved
so it but but I would just add one other
category of thinking here we have what
we think is factual and methods by which
we derive facts and I would put
rationality there and an empirical
engagement with with reality then we
have other good things in life like
fiction and and flights of fancy that
are pleasing for one reason or another
and could be generative toward the first
category but then we also have
I know I would acknowledge we've spoken
about this before useful fictions and
cases I would you know hope rare cases
where where fiction is more adaptive or
more useful than the truth right that
there's a sometimes the truth can can be
not worth knowing and I would argue that
they you know there are those cases okay
but they're not so they're few and far
between but we should focus on that but
some degree of so I wanted to point to
Douglas here and focus on that because I
think your fear Douglas is that my style
or you know Richard Dawkins or style or
Christopher Hitchens a style of anti
theism you know just let's let's just
throw the vicar's from the rooftops now
because it's time to end this thing
literally get off Twitter now but yeah
that's a hashtag yeah yes your concern
has been that and I think what Jordan
shares this that that so much of what is
good in our Western developed societies
is the very least maintained by mayn't
maintaining so-called judeo-christian
values or the or the remnants of our
past religiosity and that you know there
is a baby in the bath water that can be
difficult to discern and we can to empty
the tub all at once because and this is
very much of because there's a zero-sum
contest with the the religious
enthusiasm we see coming from the Muslim
world and of course the Muslim world is
all over the world at the moment so in
that contest between a very an older
style of religiosity
and the theocracy really and modernity
you are not as eager as I have been to
to pull up Western religiosity by the
roots or chocolate vicars yes yes I
think that's fair I think I sit
metaphorically as well as literally
between the two of you I realized from
our conversation in Dublin
some of what your concerns are about
what Jordan has been saying and what he
is saying and I share some of
the concern I said to you then that I
used the analogy of water and Eric
Weinstein recently described to me as
Jesus smuggling but it was a consequence
of a discussion about biologists what do
you do if you're discussing design
intelligent design you can be okay as
long as your own bandwidth on this on
the issue as long as your own depth of
knowledge on the issue is very
considerable you can be okay discussing
that biology with somebody even a
fundamentalist Christian so long as you
can follow every step of the way but the
fear will always be at the moment you're
not looking they're gonna smuggle Jesus
in or they'll wait till the moment that
you're not comfortable anymore with the
argument the bit when you're at the very
end of your cognitive ability and then
they'll trust me there's Jesus there's
Jesus and one of the things I realized
from Dublin was although I think you may
not think that Jordan himself is going
to try Jesus smuggling on you you fear
that somewhere down the line from what
he's saying somebody else will do that
trick yes it's worse than that I
actually know the people the people who
were clapping are doing that I hear from
those people on a daily basis right so
that the segment of Jordan's audience
that is that is very happy to be told
they can stay on the riverbanks of their
traditional Christianity for the most
part and they don't have to get into the
stream of totally monitor and rigorous
rational thinking about everything from
first principles right that there's
something that that the Iron Age scribes
got right and it's right for all time
those are those are the applause I'm
hearing and and and however consciously
or not
Jordan is telling them it's okay to stay
stick right there with a with a shard of
the cross actually tried a little
conscious Jesus smuggling on Sam to see
how that would
in a discussion we had about the central
archetype of superheroes but I'm gonna
try something a little different tonight
I'm gonna try a little direct God
smuggling we won't bother with Jesus
let's go right to God why not so one of
the things I've really tried to do when
I've been analyzing religious texts is
to take them as to take them seriously
in the sense that I don't presume that I
understand them and I presume that
they're a mystery of sorts and at least
the Bible for example is a mystery
because we don't really understand the
processes by which it was constructed
and we don't understand the processes by
which we all agreed collectively over
several thousand years to organize the
book the way it is organized or to edit
it the way that it's edited or the and
to keep what's in it and to and to
discard what's not in it and why it's
lasted and why it's had such a huge
impact why I don't want to derail you
but we do understand that the first part
of the process all too well we know that
the this there was a political and
all-too-human process of voting certain
texts in for inclusion and some were in
for centuries and then got jettisoned
and and sure a revelation came in far
later than whole generations of
Christians who lived and died under the
banner of the Bible and it was a
different Bible at the time they had the
wrong Bible so well but it's the same
it's the same issue that that we really
don't just we really don't understand
fair enough Sam and I'm not saying that
political etcetera considerations didn't
enter into it I'm sure all human
considerations entered into it but there
was some collective process of winnowing
and you can attempt to reduce that to
economic or political causes which is
generally what secular Assessors like
Freud and Marx both did and with a fair
degree of success I might add but
there's still some mysterious assessment
of what it is that will be remembered
that entered into it but it's a separate
point to some degree I'm just saying
that my point my my point of departure
when looking at these texts is one of an
essential radical ignorance I don't
that I understand the mechanisms by
which they were generated or edited or
collected or kept or remembered or why
they had the impact they had now I've
been thinking a lot about the idea of
let's say God the Father because that's
a very common archetypal representation
of God God the Father so I'm going to
tell you an experience that I had that
I've never really told any audience
about I had a vision at one point that
and the vision had to do with a dialogue
that I was having with my father and you
know you have a father right and when
you're a little kid you act out your
father when you pretend to be a father
and what you're doing when you're acting
out your father isn't imitating your
father because you don't duplicate
precisely the actions that your father
ever took in his life what you do is you
you watch your father across multiple
contexts and you abstract out something
like a spirit of the Father and then
when you're a child you implement that
spirit of the father in your pretend
play and you come to embody that deeply
so the notion is that people can
abstract out something like a spirit of
the Father and that that's part of our
min pneumatic tendency which is a very
powerful human cognitive tendency and in
this vision I first started to talk with
my father and I would say more with the
spirit of my father because he wasn't
actually there and I would say it was
the wisest part of him and then that
sort of transformed into a discussion
that I had with a series of ancestral
spirits and then that transformed itself
into a vision of God himself with whom I
had a conversation and this was a
visionary experience and then that all
went away and I spent months and months
thinking about it and I thought so you
guys can tell me what you think about
this and this sort of stretches my
cognitive ability to to its utmost limit
to contemplate such things but here's a
biological argument I already made the
case that a child can extract out the
spirit of the father and embody it and
that's necessary insofar as you're going
to be a father in the wise one but we
can also extract out the spirit of the
father over much longer periods of time
because my father was a father because
he imitated his fall
who imitated his father who imitated his
father as far back in time as you can go
and there's a cumulative development of
the Spirit of the Father across time now
then the question might be does this
spirit of the father have any reality
other than the metaphorical and I would
say damn right it has a reality and I
can describe a biological reality and
and and I don't know what this says
about any background metaphysics but
here's our hypothesis we know that human
beings separated from chimpanzees over
the course of the last 7 million years
at least in large part because of human
female sexual selectivity so it was the
spirit of femininity collectively that
helped elevate us to the degree that we
have been elevated above our chimpanzee
Co ancestor but here's in something
interesting to contemplate what is it
precisely that makes men what makes men
desirable to women and so I have a bit
of a hypothesis about that so here's
what men do they get together in
productive groups and the orient
themselves toward a certain task and
they produce a hierarchy around that
task because whenever you implement a
task you produce a hierarchy and they
vote up the most competent men to the
top of the hierarchy and then the women
select the competent men from the top of
the hierarchy but the vote that
determines who the competent men are
that are more likely to reproduce as a
consequence of male evaluation of men
and that's occurred over millennia and
so there's a spirit of the father that's
embedded in the patriarchal hierarchy
that acts as the primary selection
mechanism that offers men up to women
and plays a cardinal role in human
evolution and it looks like we've we've
personified that spirit of the father in
our religious imagery and and that's
that's how it looks to me but then
there's something that's even more
mysterious and deep about that that's
worth considering is that apparently the
entire course of evolutionary history
has conspired to produce human beings
and we could argue that it could have
been different but it certainly hasn't
been different and that means that that
selective spirit of the Father has been
part of the process that's generated our
very being and it's certainly possible
that that collective spirit of the
Father we fly
something metaphysically fundamental
about the structure of reality itself
yes well insofar as I agree with with
virtually all of that I should say that
none of that should give comfort to
people who want to hold on to this
notion that certain of our books might
have been revealed by the creator of the
universe well it depends on what you
mean by the creator like well you know
I'm just saying that that that the world
we're living in now is one in which we
have whole societies shattered over this
notion that some books weren't written
by human beings right there's a
different class of book right there's a
different shelf in the library where the
the products of almost certainly merely
human brains are venerated for all time
and and considered uneditable and unag
nora Bulai by the majority of human
beings yeah it's it's clear clear that
revelation can devolve into but
unbelievers are real but any there's a
risk in all this always is is it often
made critique but that when you're
talking about religion you're talking
about the Inquisition you're talking
about the jihadists you're not talking
about somebody who wants to go to their
local Anglican Church once a year maybe
get the children to school and maybe
when they're at some desolate moment of
their lives returns to this as the place
that stores meaning I mean the thing
that I think Jordan and I are in
agreement on in this is is that thing
quote from shop and how and the dialogue
on religion when he says you know the
truth may be like water and needs
vessels to carry it and when we were
talking about this the other night you
know you admitted that one of the
consequences perhaps of the you know the
parents sort of going through the belief
structures they may not believe in
anymore
but they keep doing it as a
demonstration of what you said was the
the you know the non embarrassing
options that atheists have come up with
but it may also be that that since we
don't have very many vessels
that cracked and damaged and sometimes
transparent as they are what vessels you
have might be worth holding on to
well no I think I think the challenge
here is I mean it feels that well first
of all we should first notice that these
comments very often take the form of you
and I don't need this stuff but most
other people do right and that is it
can't do it yes I mean that's inevitably
and if it is it's sort of to took that
format one moment the other night
whereas where you acknowledge that that
people of low intelligence are best
placed in a conservative paradigm like
traditionally conservative paradigm
because there's less to think through
right now obviously you don't want your
your view on religion summarized by it's
good for stupid people well I do I do
want to summarize to some degree that
way because for the opportunity again to
put a foot in your mouth I would say not
not only I mean the thing is is that
we're all stupid and and some of us are
far stupider than others but we're not
we're not that stupid well but there's
another problem Sam I think and and and
this is obviously a contentious one one
of the things I I don't go to church but
there is one thing I admire about the
church and that is that it's managed to
serve as a repository for these
fundamental underlying fictions for two
millennia and that's really something
bloody unbelievable I mean the great
what would you say is bloody
unbelievable look Sam there everything's
everything's everything's soaked in
blood we have no disagreement about that
but the secular alternatives that we
produced in the 20th century were
certainly no less blood sword and they
produced nothing of any program within
it whatsoever we did not do it now but
we have to put to bed that secular
canard what we are using well it's just
it's just not so that Stalinism was the
product of secularism or atheism and nor
was that product
it wasn't an inevitable project or is
our product
well it wasn't Bey and please anyone who
has this meme in in your head please
just allow the next sentences I speak to
just push it out because it's I'm so
sick of hearing this this this idea that
the greatest crimes of the 20th century
were somehow the product of atheism
right they say when you look at what
actually engineered these atrocities it
was something that looked very much like
a religion it was a religion in every
way apart from an explicit commitment to
other worldliness it was based on that's
a bit different dis dogmatism through
and through it was based on a
personality cults that that grew up
around figures like Stalin and Hitler
and now it's these were it was not the
ideas of Bertrand Russell and David Hume
that brought us to the gulag or to
Auschwitz but then you say it's the
thoughts of Jesus Christ I very well
know it's true no I can say that I can
say it was the thought of st. Augustine
and I can say it was the thought of st.
Thomas Aquinas explicitly that gave us
the Inquisition this is the fact it can
I make a suggestion yeah I mean this is
a general one as well as one for tonight
but the whole discussion I mean I said
the other night in Dublin that to a
great accessory books are written about
the period we're living in they'll
probably be described as the post
Holocaust period in history the
post-world War two ERA in Europe it's
still going on they were still we're
still going through this try to work out
what happened and I have to say one
thing that I had any rated equally tired
of is the claim that this has got to be
a tennis game between the religious and
the non-religious but people say that
the 20th century's crimes were committed
by atheists sometimes true often wrong
or that the 20th century's crimes were
committed by people who are religious
sometimes true often wrong why do you
think nobody you're not observing a
crucial distinction here because I would
never be tempted to hold religion
accountable for the bad things that
religious people do that have no
connection to religion right so if a
Muslim Rob's a liquor store I'm not
gonna blame Islam for that there's no
job
not a us there's no doctrine that makes
sense of that behavior what I blame
religion for and likewise there's no
doctrine in the mere loss of religion a
ie atheism that gets you the gulag
right oh there is no there's not there's
not I just let me just flesh out this
point for one more a second the only
thing I blame religion for are the
things that it becomes rational to do by
the light of these beliefs if you accept
these doctrines a rational and good
person can be tempted to join Isis
that's my concern a rational and good
person can be tempted to support the
Inquisition but of the many things they
had in common this is the point that
David Berlinski made in his book what
did the nkvd have in common with
everyone who oversaw the gulag the SS
people who guarded the camps of people
who put people on trains what did they
all have in common what are they have in
common with MAO among other things they
had in common the fact that none of them
thought that God was watching them none
of them thought that they were being
observed and would be held it
you dick God is on your side we have
just as many examples where people do it
because they think God is on their side
right sure cuz I think watching and
clapping I'm not denying that I'm saying
that the attempt to make this at a
tennis match over the 20th century's
mistake we we're still trying to work
out what caused it religion had a role a
fizz amader role but that the perpetual
tennis match of it I think well and
there is something to be said at a more
sophisticated level I would say for the
idea that you have an obligation to a
transcendent ethic now you make that
claim in the moral landscape you lay out
a transcendent ethic in my estimation
that's one that puts the onus of the of
responsibility on the individual to act
in a way that at minimum minimizes
suffering and so and you think of that
as a statement of fact that that's
the proper way of being and I think
about it as an axiomatic statement of
faith and that's one of our differences
but I have been very careful in my
analysis of the relationship between the
idea of sovereignty and the idea of
religious belief and one of the things
that I have worked out I think partly
from reading such people as le atta and
Jung was that the there is an emergent
idea of sovereignty that does involve
being accountable to a god and here's
how he would justify that and I would
think about this essentially from a
practical and biological perspective
independent of any metaphysical reality
that it might have so the ancient
Mesopotamians for example believed that
their emperor was the incarnation or the
representative of a god named Marduk and
that actually bestowed certain ethical
responsibilities on the ruler and so the
ruler had to be a good Marduk in order
to be a sovereign to be regarded as
sovereign he had to be the embodiment of
these divine principles and it took the
Mesopotamians a very very long period of
time perhaps several tens of thousands
of years they weren't Mesopotamian
during that whole time obviously to work
out what those principles of sovereignty
should be and the Mesopotamians encoded
this in their fictions and their
religious fictions making essentially
the proposition that the proper ruler
had to have eyes all the way around his
head because that was one of the
attributes of Marduk so he was someone
who was genuinely paying attention who
was capable of coming into voluntary
contact with with the great chaotic sub
structure of being and cutting it into
pieces and making the habitable world
and also speaking words that were
truthful that that had the power the
magic power of truth and the the the
ruler had to act that out if he was
going to be the sort of ruler that his
people weren't entitled to slay and
sacrifice and then once a year at the
new year's festival he would go outside
the city the walled city and he would
act out his role of Marduk and the
priests would humiliate him and ask him
to confess all the ways that he hadn't
been
good Marduk so that he could remember
that he had a responsibility to
undertake this this to embody this
relationship with these divine
principles and the thing that's so
important about this so absolutely
crucially important is that it
established the principle that even if
you were at the top of a hierarchy
you weren't absolute there was something
above you that you were subordinate to
and one of the extraordinarily useful
ideas about the abstraction of even God
as a personified spirit let's say is
that it allows every leader to be
subordinate to something that's beyond
him now that doesn't mean it can't be
misused but it's a very very very
important idea except you can also you
can get there the other way around you
can realize that you even if you're at
the top of the hierarchy you are
radically dependent on everyone else but
the tip of a hierarchy doesn't believe
that sometimes they believe what they
quote whatever the hell they want but
I'm saying if you if you're going to
believe something that's compatible with
with rationality globally and has the
least conceivable downside I would put
in that place not a superstitious
attachment to a notion of an invisible
friend or Punisher who's above you I
would put in its place
they totally defensible and and palpably
true fact that we that even you could be
the king of the event of the world and
you are dependent on everyone around you
to eat to not be murdered by them I mean
like you are like you are you are I mean
it's it's amazing it's amazing how
precarious even a a totalitarian regime
is I mean the amazing thing is that that
these last at all because in many cases
it would just take 50 people to act in
unison to kill the tyrant right but it
never happens because we either so have
a first mover problem everyone is afraid
to be the first person shot but it is it
is a genuine mystery that these systems
even perpetuate themselves and when they
unravel when you see you know Qaddafi
being murdered in a crowd you realize
wow it really is
just a matter of the restraint and fear
of human beings keeping any of these
things together
a benign if you if you wanted a
hierarchy where you had a kind of
philopon ein philosopher-king
well pulling the reins of a society I'm
not saying we do but even there
you could have an ethical one you could
have one where an anon superstitious one
with one where someone recognized hey
this is this is how we're doing it but
we are radically I at the top of the
hierarchy I'm radically dependent on
having being surrounded by as many happy
people as possible well look I mean I
don't I don't in some profound sense I
disagree what we're actually late you
know we're living this sounds like a
fiction but we're living with this
problem and we encounter this more and
more when you talk you know in Silicon
Valley as you and I occasionally do and
I'm sure you do as well where you meet
people who are fantastically wealthy who
seem uncannily detached at the by the
detach at the fact that the there's this
growing chasm between them and those
they know and the rest of humanity and
then and you one who begins to wonder
what level of wealth inequality will
everyone find alarming and some people
are acting as though there is no level
that is alarming that there's the kind
of a law of nature that this thing can
grow it just impossibly to the point
where we have trillionaire is walking
around and you know in driving in their
motor caves and it's kind of as sort of
the libertarian religion one
occasionally runs into and clearly
there's some level of inequality that's
untenable or at least would be
undesirable there well it's it's a funny
thing because that's a place where our
thought loops and then agrees to some
degree again because I do believe that
you can in some sense rationally derive
an an ethic so so let's let let's take
the argument that you put forward and
say that well you're and this is an
extension of your well-being argument to
something
which ever with which I've thought about
a fair bit it's like well okay what's
the optimal solution for you well okay
well first of all there isn't just you
now there's you now and you tomorrow and
you next week and you in a year
you in five years so there's you and the
you that propagates across time so one
of the implications of that is that you
can't do anything that's really good for
the you now that isn't very good for you
a week from now right so that means you
have to imagine yourself as multiple
individuals across multiple timeframes
and then you have to figure out what's
good for all those individuals across
all those time frames although you
discount the future to some degree
because of its unpredictability but then
so that's a very tight set of
constraints and you might say well a
rational person would calculate what was
optimal across all those all those
multiple timeframes then you do the same
thing with other people which is the
point you just made well it isn't just
you because who's you there's you and
your family and most people are in a
situation where they would regard damage
to their family as perhaps even worse
than damage to them so whatever they are
obviously encapsulate s-- their family
and then to some degree that flows off
into the community and so there is no
isolated you and then that's sort of
yeah point with regards to the ethic but
then so so I agree with all that but
then one of the things that I would
suggest is that because that's an
incredibly in in difficult rational
calculation and perhaps an impossible
one technically speaking but for
certainly very difficult that's what
that what has happened in part as our as
our great narratives havoc have emerged
across time is that we have observed
ourself attempting to solve that
multiple identity multiple time frame
problem and we've told stories about
people who do that exceptionally well
and then we've whittled out those
stories and we've produced these
powerful narratives that encapsulate the
ethic that does in fact reflect that
wisdom and so so and I think you
actually accept some of that in your in
your moral propositions which is
something that we've talked about before
so for example although never really
agreed on you certainly believe for
example
that the embodiment of truth is one of
the means whereby you solve the problem
of ethics and I would say that that's a
deeply rooted judeo-christian concept
that that so deeply rooted that it that
it precedes any notion of religious
provincialism it's deeper than
judeo-christian it's deeper than our
humanity on some level at one point we
talked about the Golden Rule and I said
that you think that the the precursor to
the Golden Rule can be found even among
monkeys right right Golden Rule is the
ground rule even for monkeys yes exactly
exactly and sort of let me just add to
the picture you sketched out I
completely agree with we have a we have
an ethical obligation even to our future
selves right I mean we are in
relationship to who we will who's going
to be the person is drinking his fourth
scotch tonight will be well it has some
ethical relationship to the person who's
going to wake up with a hangover
tomorrow morning and we and one thing we
know for sure in which we have begun to
dimly understand and describe
scientifically is that we're bad at all
of these calculations
yes hyperbolic discounting of future
rewards well that's also why I think we
have these stringent limitations on
rationality Sam is that we can't solve
the problem through calculation well no
but we increasingly can and and even
where it's best summarized not by
capital what one thing I'll grant you is
that it's not always best conveyed or
rendered indelible and actionable by
being given a nature paper or you know a
saw an abstract from from a paper in the
literature and being told this is the
way you want to behave to maximize your
well-being it may best be conveyed by
certain stories right or certain books
that are that are in the philosophy
section of the bookstore not the science
section and maybe where you and I were
at the book signing the other night and
someone came up with with a copy of the
meditations of Marcus Aurelius write a
fantastic book there's so much wisdom in
that book right and there's nothing
about stoning a girl to death if she's
not a virgin on her wedding day now we
all recognize that Marcus Aurelius was a
human being who wrote this book
and that that Providence is no barrier
to take in the book deadly seriously
it's an incredibly useful book and
stoicism a stoicism could be the quote
religion or the guiding philosophy of
the West it could it would be a much
better one than Judaism or Christianity
and and as have not virtue aliy none of
the downside and and so that's my point
that we're in this perverse circumstance
of being held hostage by certain
products of literature and we need to
break the spell and if and if we're
finding it this hard to break what do we
think is gonna happen in the Middle East
or in the sub-saharan Africa I mean we
the moral progress we need to engineer
is a common humanity coming together
those shared values those are perfectly
credible arguments but but the weakness
in the argument I think is the one that
we started to talk about earlier which
is that when you talked with Dave Rubin
a while back and Michael Shermer said
the same thing recently he he basically
said that atheism is it is a doctrine of
negation that's what I said with Rubin
is that there isn't that positive a
ethos and atheism all it says is that
there's no there's nothing personified
there's nothing personified transcendent
it's something like that there is no God
and so and so the problem with the
Atheist it's not even the assertion that
there is no God it's just that it's a
failure to be convinced by any of the
gods on offer [ __ ] it's just like not
believing in Zeus fine and it's not like
it's a weak it's not like it's a weak
argument I mean I'm perfectly aware that
making a de istic case or a case for
religion in the face of the claims of
the rationalist atheists is perhaps well
it's a very very difficult thing to
manage but it is also the case that and
and this is where I think we differ with
regards to what happens say in the
Soviet Union and perhaps to to also in
Nazi Germany is that when when when when
your doctrine demolishes the that's
called it the literary or fictional sub
structure
and leaves nothing behind an F Oh an
ethos needs to be provided because
something will rush in to fill the void
and it's certainly the case and this is
what Nietzsche warned about even though
he was a strident anti-christian and
it's also what Dostoevsky first saw he
said if we knock out the logos from the
substructure of Western society and we
need to believe that it was
Christianity's emphasis on truth that
destroyed Christianity which was an
extremely an interesting criticism you
know the Christian adhere the elevators
to truth to such a degree that it was it
actually resulted in the demolition of
its own dogmatic sub structure but be
that as it may Nietzsche's
prognostication was that if we allowed
God to die and perhaps there were
reasons for that that the consequence
would be that would we would be awash in
both nihilism and totalitarian bloodshed
and that is what happened in the 20th
century and so so and there's another
there's another aspect to that which is
if you may you may try to knock out the
whole thing take out some of the
substructure but not the whole thing
that's what Nietzsche also shows but his
prediction I think is blindingly
obviously true that you might in this
post Christian era have a remand of
Christianity such as guilt overbearing
guilt and no means of alleviation or
redemption which is actually part of the
problem of Protestantism by the way
because it's you know and and and there
are other things to that it seemed to be
that it seemed to be fundamental
religious issues that the secularists I
think have a difficult time accounting
for it's like so you actually have to
grapple seriously with the problem that
a doctrine that's essentially one of
negation doesn't offer a positive ethos
and now an E and you are doing now to be
perfectly fair you said that reading a
nature paper about the necessity of
calculating your ethic across multiple
multiple time frames and multiple
persons doesn't have the motive force
that's going to drive you to act
ethically in life and I do believe
that's true but I think the fact that
the rationalist ethos doesn't have
motivational push is actually a fatal
flaw they don't
every week to read marcus aurelius yeah
and they don't like there's no music
that goes along with it there's no art
that goes along with it there's no
architecture that goes along with it
like weifare but to be fair to the
present most music and most art and most
architecture yes is no longer religious
that it has flown the perch provided by
religion traditionally and most of what
we care about in increasingly
cosmopolitan at the end secular
societies is not tied to religion in any
direct way and there's even whole
religions like Judaism where you have to
look long and hard to find anyone who
believes much of anything that is
religious
I have literally sat on stage debating
what I thought was a religious rabbi who
was a conservative rabbi and when I
asked when I said something that assumed
that he believed in a God who could hear
prayers he threw up his hands and he
said what makes you think I believe in a
God who can hear prayers and I thought I
was just you know I practically lost the
debate just in in my astonishment you
know it's like wait wait you know what
does it mean to be a conservative rabbi
in this case there are religions that
have made that transition to a an
increasingly attenuated commitment to
the truth of the doctrine and there are
religions who haven't moved an inch
right and we and and it but I think we
have to acknowledge that that this this
movement in this direction is progress
because what it what it actually is at
bottom is increasing sensitivity to the
difference between having good reasons
and bad reasons for what you believe
right and and the fact that that this
book has been around forever is not a
good reason the fact that mommy hates it
so well it's actually it's not a
terrible reason though because the fact
that something has lasted for that
length of time at least makes the fact
that it's lasted a mystery and you can't
just attribute that to casual
politicking or economic circumstances
there's through something
look you can say about many of the
biblical stories is that they're
incredibly memorable and that means that
in some sense they're adapted to the
memory structures of boys so is the the
mythology of ancient Greece it's
incredibly memorable but I'm but I don't
know luck all those gods are dead the
stories still can be useful
yeah the gods on let's say yeah but it
lives on in a way that is benign it
lives on in a way where you learn about
them in mythology class in school right
you you don't have it you don't have a
fear of Hades drummed into you as a
child by your parent no the other thing
that is lacking as far as I can tell in
the in the rationalist doctrine and this
is something that I've observed in my
clinical practice and so one of the
things that's happened over the last
year is that I've had many people
especially ex-soldiers come to my
lectures who have post-traumatic stress
disorder and they say that listening to
my lectures especially the ones on good
evil and tragedy there's a particularly
sure that I suppose you might be you
might think about as devoted to people
at post-traumatic stress disorder and
that the language of good and evil that
I lay out in those lectures is actually
what allows them to recover from the
post-traumatic stress disorder and
dealing with people like that in my
clinical practice the same thing has
been the case if we can't transcend the
language of the merely rational and move
into an intense conversation about good
and evil in some sense as metaphysical
realities we can't enter a realm of
seriousness conceptual seriousness
that's of sufficient depth to help heal
someone who's been touched by
malevolence because that actually is
what happens to people with
post-traumatic stress disorder is that
inevitably the reason that there are so
shattered isn't because something tragic
has happened to them although that does
happen upon occasion it's because
someone malevolent has made contact with
them and sometimes that malevolent being
let's say orb level and force or spirit
for lack of a better word is something
that resides within them and so there we
have these limits on rational debt and
the reason I'm making this case is
because we've already identified another
limit of rational discourse it's like it
doesn't have the motivating power of
great fiction and great literature and
great poetry but it also doesn't have
the healing power of language that that
takes the ethical realm to its extreme
in some sense and and then the next
problem with that and this is something
that Douglas has been has been
contemplating I would say is that what
what evidence do we have that a merely
secular representation a rational
representation of our ethic is going to
provide us with a motive force that
would be sufficient for us to do such
things as identify what's valuable about
our culture and be motivated to
sufficiently protected assuming that we
do something of protection but we know
it what a few of those things are and
they have they have nothing to do with
what's on the inside of a church or a
synagogue or a mosque they have to do
with things like free speech right like
the trench we are all fighting in is at
least one of them is defense of the free
exchange of ideas and that is put in
peril by many kinds of orthodoxies but
some are the old orthodoxy is the
blasphemy laws and the people who want
you know apostates to be killed
we're leaving in this case Islam so it's
it's a that those are some of the sacred
I would even if we were gonna list the
the sacred artifacts of art that that
keeps that keep our society worth living
in there it's I think the list is gonna
be very long before we start getting to
the the actual sacred objects of any one
faith but we'll be things like freedom
of speech and freedom of assembly and
and the the the free exchange of ideas
across boundaries the fact that we are
no longer religiously or linguistically
or geographically partitioned in the
ideas we can entertain well it seems to
me though like and this may be my own my
own idiosyncratic reading of the of the
of the domain but when I look at
something like like I
and considered a cathedral dome let's
say and there are very very old
cathedral domes that have an image of
Christ put up against the dome right so
as as creator of the cosmos okay and I'm
trying to look at that from a
psychological and even a biological
perspective and what I see is the
elevation of a particular image that
represents an ideal and so the the the
Christ that's represented on the on the
on the dome of a cathedral is something
that's projected up into celestial space
so it's it's an ideal to which you are
supposed to be subordinate or that
you're supposed to embody and the ideal
is the ideal of the logos technically
speaking the logos the word made flesh
which is not only the word free speech
for lack of a better term but also the
embodiment of that elevated to the
highest principle and and and that is
given status as the creator of the
universe and the reason for that in part
and this is written into the
judeo-christian doctrine right from line
one is the idea that it's through the
discourse that you value so much that we
actually engender the world as such and
that is a divine principle and it's it's
also in my reading the divine image of
God that men and women are made in and
so what I see in the underlying
metaphysic where you see superstition
and and fundamentalism and look fair
enough and it's not like I would ever
argue that that's not a danger I see the
imagistic and and and dramatized
representation of exactly the idea that
you hold to be paramount above all else
which is your commitment to truth
expressed in speech okay what's my
concern and this is this is where I
started with you is that you could give
the same charitable reading of astrology
and you'd even be tempted to do it as we
as we talk about astrology as you showed
at the outset now but I don't why is it
a charitable reading Sam how else would
you explain the existence of something
like a cathedral with that hey what the
hell I'm people going when they built
I'm saying we could is it's by dint of
mere historical contingency and
questionable look that we're not living
in a world where the cathedrals
have stained-glass windows with signs of
the zodiac on them right we could be in
that world what we are we were very
close to being in our in that world to
some degree because the astrological
endeavor in the judeo-christian
landscape expanded to incorporate
Christianity and there's an entire
astrology of Christianity including
representation yes but my point is is
that we recognize that the literal
claims of astrology the the mechanism by
which astrologers think it works is
intellectually bankrupt right and if any
significant mayhem were being caused by
people's commitment to astrology if we
had presidents of the United States who
couldn't get elected unless unless they
paid lip-service to a literal belief in
astrology if we had presidents who were
consulting their astrologers to figure
out when to meet with other world
leaders right the this this would be a
problem that that rational people would
recognize me astrology can be disproven
in a single hour you simply have to go
to a one hospital in one city sometime
and find find two unrelated children
born in the safe within 20 feet of each
other and follow their lives and if they
have different lives than then there's
then signs of the zodiac mean nothing
part of your argument is and invalidly
so is how in the world do we determine
which revelatory axioms are worthy of
respect and of maintenance and fair
enough salmon maybe none well maybe a
revelatory maybe that's not it is just a
matter of K conscious agents like
ourselves having better and better
conversations well that well it is
certainly partly that it is certainly
partly that but let me again revelation
the I in my book is nothing other than
the record of past conversations so
you've either got Iron Age conversations
shaping your worldview or you have
conversations like these shaping your or
you have both you could have both but
then you have a dialogue with the past
let's beautiful which brings me to
Marcus Aurelius I read him with great
pleasure and great and and
and astonishment frankly I mean that
yeah it is such a modern and edifying
take on ethics and and one's own
personal well-being and just not getting
just not being encumbered by by thoughts
and and and vanities that that are that
are so easy to cut through once you
notice them but so captivating and
arranging of your life when you don't
and he I mean there's no wisdom in that
book then then then almost any book I
can name and you don't have to believe
any [ __ ] to honor okay let me offer
you a continued explication here so and
you didn't answer my question about what
all these crazy medieval people were
doing spending almost all of their
excess capital building a representation
of the sky and putting an image on that
so just hang on a sec so so let's talk
about what it would mean to embody the
truth so there's a deep idea in
Christianity that this is what it would
mean it would mean to confront the
suffering of life voluntarily to its
fullest which would mean to accept the
necessity of death and betrayal at the
hands of your fellow men without undue
bitterness to accept that voluntarily
and to still understand that your
fundamental ethical task is to work
towards the redemption of the world and
that's associated with that image that's
cast upon the heavenly dome and and that
isn't a charitable reading Sam that's
that that's an essential analysis of the
fundamental doctrines of Christianity
yes but I could do the same thing with
Buddhism and give you a slightly
different story but nonetheless
inspiring and edifying and I could do
the same thing with it but we can't do
it with rationality but I can do it I
can do it with Greek no no no that's not
true I yeah I can do it with Greek
mythology I can do with any of these
domains but the the crucial bit for me
is that in order to make use of those
stories I don't have to believe in
Revelation I don't have to put I don't
have to believe that you get everything
you want after you die no no but but I'm
talking about the applause of
conventionally religious people who
think that their conventional religion
is in some way cashed out or redeemed or
supported by the reading you're given
now of the of Christ in
starry heavens it's not unless you're
adding this other piece which is some
probabilistic claim that yes this book
probably was dictated by an omniscient
Dean unlike any other book well or maybe
the Muslims are right that our angel
Gabriel did show up to Muhammad in his
cave and give him the one final
revelation never to be superseded and
just on the merits of the text we know
that's not true we know for all it gets
wrong and all it fails to get right
about the nature of our circumstance we
know that book is not the best book ever
written on any topic and here I'm
speaking of the Quran but it's true of
the Bible it's true it's true of the
meditations of Marcus Aurelius but the
book but but no one's claiming that
about the meditations and that's a
crucial difference it's a difference
that that explains so much unnecessary
suffering in our world and again what I
fear about the way you talk about
religion is that at the end of all these
conversations I'm still not sure what
you believe on that point frankly and if
I'm not sure no one out there is well I
don't know why I don't know why you
would expect to be sure about what
someone believes how do you think that
any one of you are capable of fully
articulating what you believe you
certainly aren't you are no I it's
completely ridiculous
you're not transparent to yourself by
any stretch of the imagination
you act out all sorts of things that you
can't articulate butthat but how about
if how about a best-guess ya know if you
look let's go all cognitive neuroscience
on this shall we
ninety-nine percent of your processing
is unconscious you're not capable of
articulating yourselves if you were
you'd be omniscient okay but that's
gonna give me any nonsense about that
for that that is a
[Applause]
I've never heard so many people applaud
an evasion of a simple question it was a
good yeah okay I honestly yes everything
you just said about not being fully
transparent to yourself is true and you
are ruled by committee in there all the
time no doubt but I'm at I'm asking what
you actually believe I mean there's
several things I can ask I mean almost
any one of these threads can can pull
the whole tapestry but to take
Christianity as an example what do you
believe about this the origin of this
sacred book the Bible old a New
Testament do you believe that just maybe
it has a status unlike any other book or
is it simply old writing of human beings
just like ourselves I think it's both
okay so but but but so what does that
mean that you're saying you're saying
that there's somebody who's taking
dictation that is unlike any other
dictation so it's so Homer though
creators or Shakespeare is operated
within hours of inspiration okay
everyone's been inspired if you talk to
creative people yes they say they often
describe themselves as something
approximating a conduit through which
higher wisdom is pouring again you're
dodging shakes that Shakespeare could
say that and yeah and any writer can say
that yeah and it's also the case that we
would or we would rank organize we would
rank order those writers which is why
you pointed to Shakespeare in terms of
the generalizable validity of their
revelations sure and so well look so you
run into the same issue you know you
criticize the Bible and look fair enough
you know man but you're you're also
evading a very important issue which is
how do you how do you quantitatively
rank the contributions of literature
without assuming that there's a
hierarchy of Revelation you although
this a hierarchy of wisdom sure there's
a heart a hierarchy of human wisdom I
will grant you that every day of the
week but this it is but we're talking
about primates like ourselves having
conversations and this is the most
important game we can play
this is the best game in town and it has
always been so but people are imagining
and it includes as you said at the
outset what I would call spiritual
experience and spiritual experience is
admits of a fact-based discussion about
the nature of human consciousness and
why do you allow that as an exception
like because it's not an exception as
part of that the data set so it's
possible to have the e ritual so this is
spiritual experience without the
possible of possibility of concretize
revelation so it's a formless
spirituality that you're advocating no
no it you can have a money even I'm not
even discounting the possibility that
there are invisible entities out there
in the universe far smarter than
ourselves who we could possibly be in
dialogue with I mean there are many
strange ideas that we could defend to
one or another degree of you that
they're people walking around
speculating that we might be living in a
computer simulation that all of this is
being run on some hard drive of the
future or or some you know alien
supercomputer now that you can actually
I mean Nick Bostrom at Oxford gives a
very cogent argument in defense of that
thesis right now you can you can deal
with that on its merits I'm not saying
the universe isn't stranger than we
suppose or even can suppose but one
thing we know is that when you read the
Bible you can turn every page of that
book and you will not find evidence of
omniscience you will not find anything
in there that someone as smart as
Shakespeare or actually a little bit
dumber could have written no I don't
think that's true Sam they're incredibly
potent there's whatever I'd say about
the biblical writings that are
incredibly potent but so it's impossible
to write something virtually impossible
to write something like Cain and Abel
it's a paragraph in shame you're saying
the Shakespeare the Shakespeare of the
two 3,000 years ago couldn't have
written Genesis he couldn't have written
to Cain and Abel not intends it so that
so then it's okay enable is 10 sentences
long so then who gains more wisdom than
you can then you can dig okay let's go
now but now we're getting to the nub of
it then you think
because that it was not the product of a
human mind I think it was the product of
a vast collection of human minds working
over millennia okay so we have a city of
Shakespeare's so but still which is
really what we so we've just got people
about this and this but this concession
if indeed you're making it and I'm still
not sure is the eradication of
traditional Christianity if something is
deeply wise its reflective of a deeper
reality otherwise it wouldn't be what
I've okay I'm in love with deeper
realities the deeper reality that
something is wise is the story of Cain
and Abel reflection it's the real a
landscape of mind that we we are that
either takes great training great luck
or pharmacological bombardment of the
human brain to explore right there
there's a way there are ways to get
there there are ways to have the
beatific vision right and and if and we
will we understand this to some degree
but experientially and we can understand
it to some degree by by this
third-person methods of science and it's
not it's not like I don't know I've had
many experiences that if I had them in a
religious context would have counted for
me as evidence of the truth of my
religion right but because I I have was
not brought up up in a religious context
and because I spend a lot of time seeing
the downside of that form of credulity I
have never been tempted to interpret
these experiences that way try a higher
dose yeah I've tried believe me yes oh
I'll go I'll play that game of poker
with you all day long you know surprise
yes well maybe maybe maybe there's our
next podcast yeah did you just see a
card that I've got to ask all of you a
question now so we're an hour and 15
minutes into this discussion and
hypothetically what we will do is stop
and and go to Q&A but our
experience so far has been that when we
asked the audience because we have done
that each time whether we've asked the
audience whether we should continue or
whether we should go to Q&A so the first
thing I'm going to do and you can vote
on this by making a certain amount of
noise if you're inclined to do so how
many of you would like us to stop
talking and go to Q&A how many of you
would like us to continue this
discussion for 45 more minutes it's it
seems to me that it's an objective fact
it's louder people have the floor so it
really is gonna be a rude awakening when
those applause are reversed however yeah
we know it's timeless was I gonna ask
something
yeah something let's go back to let's go
back to thee to one of the core problems
that we've been trying to address which
is the the apparent failure perhaps of
the the the rationalist atheist types to
develop a an active ethos that has
sufficient beauty and motivational power
to serve as a credible replacement for
the religious rituals so there seems
there must be a reason why that's that
failure has occurred right so maybe a
short list of reasons one is that
traditionally the impulse to do that in
a religious context has been fatal right
so to declare your apostasy has been the
almost as reliable a way of committing
suicide as jumping off a building in
most cultures and most societies for the
longest time and still is in many places
as you know in the Muslim world so
if there's been a barrier to entry to
thinking creatively about alternatives
to religion and so much of atheism and
secularism is just a a pitched battle
against the the eroding power of
religion and when religion really has
its power right we know what it's like
you know they again I think what we
spoke about this at one point it just
yet at the moment that it makes this
most salient is you know Galileo being
shown the instruments of torture by men
who wouldn't look through his telescope
right I mean that's that was the point
of contact between untrammeled human
rationality and the womb that bore it
right give the religious awe at the
beauty of the heavens right so the
moment was a person like Galileo stepped
a little too far and to connect us to
astrology again Galileo was a court
astrologer right mr. doe did they were
there was a [ __ ] there was a point of
contact between astronomy and astrology
at that point so we're still under the
shadow of that kind of dogmatism and
oppression in much of the world and for
the longest time I mean it's still in
the United States you cannot run for the
presidency without pretending to believe
in God it's amazing it's amazing fact
right when will that change it someday
it will but we have we have just had
almost no time talks if it's to
experiment in this base and intervals
means some time I mean some decades I
suppose the thing that unites Sam it
would be nice to Auden to me on this is
if if we face some of the problems some
of the enemies might even say that you
identify as well and the question is
whether you should face them in the
midst of an experiment that may or may
not work ie a leap into pure rationality
or whether you might decide it's worth
among other things taking some of the
versions of things that you've had that
have been of worth in your past and
using them where they're useful well but
what do you picture in there because
there really is no leap there's no
global leap to pure rationality there's
just there's this incremental
erosion of religious answers to
terrestrial questions so there's that
yeah I guess at the moment you you have
a science of neurology you begin to look
at epilepsy not as demonic possession
but as a neurological problem before
there's a science of neurology you don't
know what the hell is happening right so
so into them say something obviously
drove Douglas I would say in some sense
surprisingly to make the assumption that
one of the things that we need to do to
defend whatever it is that we have a
value in the West assuming that we have
anything of value was something like the
reincorporation of this religious
substructure so white it's not something
that I would have expected you to
conclude oh wait what are you why did
you conclude it well partly for the
reason I just suggested that the leap
into pure rationality there's no
evidence yet that it's going to work or
there's gonna be enough for enough
people are gonna be able to partake give
me the precise amount place where you're
worried that it's gonna fail and what
can you what are you imagining
well you wake it now yeah let me give
you one example and we may be in the
midst of the discovery that the only
thing worse than religion is its absence
when we're where are we discovering that
look at the religions that people are
making up as we speak I mean every day
there's a new dogma and you and I and
Jordan have repeatedly tripped over his
dogmas
some are usually survived it has to be
said but they're stampeding to create
new religion all the time at the moment
every every new heresy that's invented
and they're not as well thought through
as past terraces they don't always have
the bloody repercussions yet but you can
easily foresee a situation in which they
do a new religion is being created as we
speak by a new generation of people who
think they are non-ideological who think
they're very rational who think their
past myth who think their past story who
think they're better than any of their
ancestors and have never bothered to
even study their answers
but can't you say that dogmatism is the
problem okay the generic problem here is
dogmatism a firm belief in the absence
of good argument and good evidence and
absolutely we can agree that dogmatism
of any kind has that danger or will
always have that danger but the void
also has a danger the void that you can
create if you throw out all the stories
that help get you to where you are also
has this danger because people come up
with these news stories and every day's
news now is about this every hour
politics is now basically about this up
I mean well and what and what's flown in
to fill the gap seems to be something
like a new tribalism absolute is exactly
what you'd expect in some sense right if
you if you demolish the superordinate
system you know religion divides people
no doubt but it also unites people yes
and so one of the things that arguably
unites people above their mere tribalism
is their Union and an abstract religious
superstructure and then if you demolish
that well then one of the things that
does seem to happen is the emergence of
a reflexive tribalism because people
need to need a group identity of sorts
and the easiest thing to do seems to be
to revert to ethnicity and race and
gender and sex etc etc and then we do
end up and have ended up in this
situation that Douglass outlines and you
know one of the things I think that
distinguishes us temperamental II
possibly maybe because you're a little
more on the liberal side and I'm a
little more on the conservative side
even temperamentally speaking is that
your fundamental terror is that of
fundamentalism although you also state
in the moral landscape that you
understand that the perils of nihilism
and I would say my fundamental terror is
that of nihilism even though I'm
susceptance ative to the catastrophes of
fundamentalism but I don't think you do
address the problem of the void
sufficiently because I don't think that
you have anything to offer except an and
I'm not trying to minimize your offering
you you make a case that people should
work
to alleviate suffering and that we
should live in truth but Jesus Sam you
can summarize that in two sentences it
doesn't have the potency of the
fictional literary artistic substructure
that seems necessary to make that into
something that's that's a compelling
story so it's the this is where we might
disagree this could be a fundamental
disagreement because I actually I don't
see the problem of nihilism the way you
do or the way it's advertised like once
you rip out the false certainties and
the bad evidence and the bad arguments
and the and the the mere dog was imposed
on us by prior generations that hole
never closes safely with anything else
you have to put something in its place
that's shaped just like that some other
false certainty or some other story I
simply don't think that's the case I
think there's so many things we outgrow
both individually a you know if in art
your own childhoods and culturally that
where there is no there is no void left
there's no Santa Claus shaped void that
we have to fill with the experience but
people certainly experienced some people
you people I'm not discounting the fact
that it is hard to be happy in this
world I mean we are living in a world
that seems designed perfectly designed
to frustrate our efforts to find
permanent happiness so you asked me what
my answer is I just think there's the
recipe for a good life or least least a
minimal recipe for a good life that's
not that this is all that's entailed but
this is this is this is certainly
necessary if not sufficient is to live a
life that is increasingly motivated by
love and guided by reason right you
can't go very far wrong if you are
motivated by love and guided by reason
right and and the problem is is that
well okay
well the first thing I would say about
that is to me that's a recapitulation of
the judeo-christian ethic which is be
guarded by love and up and use logos to
serve that that you gotta regenerate the
fine print on reason oh yeah clever
didn't say reason I said logos cuz
that's the that's something that's
deeper there there's the Jesus smuggling
yes exactly
well yes yes definitely okay so but but
so look I've been I've been trying to
part of the reason that I'm doing what
I'm doing is to try to address the void
let's say and I suspect that many of you
are actually here because you would like
to have the void addressed and so the
way it looks to me is something like
this and this is what I've derived in
part from my studies of religious
tradition so I could say that at the
beginning of Genesis for example there's
a proposition that it's truthful speech
that generates habitable order from
chaotic potential that seems to me to be
the fundamental narrative and I do
believe there's something dead accurate
and real about that because we do
generate the world as a consequence of
our communicative effort and then
there's a second proposition which is
that the world that we generate from the
the chaos of potential is habitable to
the degree that the communication that
we engage in is truthful and that's why
God who uses the logos at the beginning
of time to generate the world is able to
say that his creation is good the
proposition is the world you bring into
being through truthful speech is good
and that's the image of God that's
implanted in man and woman and there's a
grandeur about that idea and you think
well you don't need the grandeur because
it's just a fiction it's like just wait
a second here it's not just a fiction
unless you don't believe that in some
manner you partake in the creation of
the world and that you have an ultimate
responsibility that might well be
described as divine to participate in
that process properly truthfully and
with love and there's every reason to
think that that's an elevated ideal so
high that it's worthy of conceptualizing
as divine and also to presume that it
represents some fundamental metaphysical
and that's a lot more powerful than you
need to be good yes but that the problem
here Jordan
it's that I could do exactly what you
just did with Buddhism or Hinduism and
it is just as grand and just as deep and
just as anchored to the the first person
experience of contemplatives who have
taken that as far as they could take it
you know well then ask Sam you should do
that and see how people respond to it
well no no because I yes seriously no no
because I see the end of at the end of
the game it's not that doesn't arrive
where I want to get to where we need to
get to because it is it's it would be to
different effect it's to it they're
they're different claims ultimately
about the status of truth and good and
evil and about the beginning of the
world and the fate of a human
consciousness after death it's
completely they're completely
irreconcilable worldviews you know I
also do not that we're if there are
Hindus in the audience they believe
something that is totally irreconcilable
to what Christians believe I don't think
that you can offer pardon me a
watered-down version of Buddhism as a
consequence of psychedelic experience as
a cut as an acceptable and credible
alternative to the power of the
fundamental founding myths of the
Western culture and if you think you can
try no I'm trying well I'm not trying
that but that's that's not that's not
what I thought well first of all just to
just to get my biography straight it's
not just the psychedelic experience
right and I'm also not making light of
the psychedelic experience listen to
take this we're having most of this
conversation on the side of where we're
in it seems reasonable to worry about
the faith of civilization right you we
could have started at a very different
point with just the nature of
consciousness right just the just our
first person encounter with being itself
right you wake we all of us wake up each
morning we are thrust from a condition
of deep sleep which we've seen
nothing about and would just have pushed
through the veil of dreams into this
apparently solid reality that we call
the world and we're engaging one another
in this space of just consciousness and
its contents and we're trying to make
sense of it and science is the best
language game we play I would argue in
trying to make truly rigorous sense of
it but it's not doesn't exhaust all the
language games we play we play others
that are also fact-based we talk about
what happened historically before we
arrived here we talk about facts as we
can understand them that we just didn't
witness but others did and we call that
journalism right so we're trying to have
a family yes it's getting harder and
harder to discern what's actually going
on now but we are we are thrust into
this condition of being our apparent
selves moment by moment and we notice
the difference between happiness and
suffering right and this is not merely
sensory it's not merely that you know I
don't like the feeling of a hot stove
and I do like a warm bath
it's ideas the ways of thinking about
ourselves and the world can can open the
door or close the door to various states
of happiness and suffering and religion
comes into religion leverages that
people it that the difference between
believing that your dead child is in
heaven with Jesus and not being able to
believe that is enormous right I want to
ask a specific though you've expended a
certain amount of reputational energy
and much more on the jihadists in your
battles we say there how much a lie ship
to use a very Jewish term have you found
from fellow secular rational people who
want to love and reason like you well
that is a leading question isn't it
I've got fingers if you need more I know
you
your fingers are safe no unfortunately
but it's but this is a problem of I
wouldn't describe this too well
the Allies you can easily find among
deeply religious Christians say are
there for the wrong reasons right I mean
I can find you know I well know note
that the reason they're there for the
wrong that will they they see the
problem clearly for the wrong reasons so
for instance I so I meet secular
scientist types you know anthropologists
say who are so far from knowing what
it's like to believe in revelation that
they don't believe anyone else does
right so when you tell them that members
of Isis really believe that if you die
in the right circumstances you get 72
virgins and you're you're in you know
surrounded by rivers of milk and honey
and all the rest if you go into the
ivory tower you meet people who don't
believe that anyone believes that stuff
but if you go into a megachurch they
know people believe that's not because
they believe their own dogmas right
that's that's what it's like to be to be
effortlessly right for not especially
good reasons the fact that you believe a
book the fact that you believe a book
was written by God and therefore it's
trivially easy for you to understand
that someone else believes that but they
just have the wrong book that's not the
rational basis for understanding our
circumstances we're looking for I'm not
saying whether one is right and one is
wrong but one seems to have more
commitment in that and in one battle
you're fighting commitment maybe
important yeah there may be many reasons
why the people who deeply want to love
and be rational are absolutely no damn
use in that fight because they want to
preserve their happiness a bit longer
preserve their comfort a bit longer
cannot understand people who genuinely
come from a fundamentalist standpoint
yeah and then there's also other well
there to steal man their case for a
moment it is understandable to be
sensitive to
and guilty about the history of
colonialism and the reality of racism
and to be so committed to tolerance as
your master virtue that you're tempted
to tolerate intolerance and not
recognize it to be cowardice which in
fact it making tolerance your core value
is much different than making truth your
core value yes which is an interesting
thing because and perhaps this is one of
the places where you and the
fundamentalist radical leftists let's
say differ is that the core value that's
emerging there is definitely one of
tolerance whereas the core value that
you espouse is one of truth and truth
and tolerance are not the same thing and
so it might have been yeah yeah as more
as the pursuit of truth and the belief
that as a result truth can be found that
it's not a single thing on its own you
just pursue it as a hobby
there's just something you do but that
you believe that at the end of it there
is a truth to be found yeah you know so
it's over Douglas what what do you fear
is the case here if if there were more
people like me in the West right well
maybe I'm not maybe I'm the I'm the
outlier here I'm I'm somehow infected by
this over waning commitment to truth and
rationality and science and yet I'm
still motivated to worry about jihad but
you're you worried that there are many
people like me who are oblivious to the
bomb are you worried about it when so
many other people who are hypothetically
the question you ask why are you so
worried about when there's so many
people who are hypothetically like you
that don't seem to be worried about it I
mean maybe you're wrong you shouldn't be
worried about it's a possibility that's
my worry at any rate that we may be
living in an era when we are discovering
that the Enlightenment and the
Enlightenment values never went very
wide and didn't go terribly deep and
this is a very painful realization to
make but not only do we go all around
the world and discover that we find that
at home the roots turn out not to have
gone very deep in even this society and
the problem it is a problem but but
hence my my commitment to making them
deeper and and to reiterate the point
I'm very happy if it was entirely Sam
Harris's all the way down ok I'd have no
problem with that
it's just that underneath Sam Harris its
he'll know me too well
yeah and that has to be very carefully
edited on rationality in the service of
love like this isn't interesting like
I'm not sure you get to get away with
that because like is it rationality or
is it love because well I don't
understand the place in your conceptual
system for love given your emphasis on
rationality as the ethic of as the
mechanism of ethics so I would say to
the degree that I smuggle in Jesus which
by the way isn't accidental in some
sense and I'm fully conscious when I'm
doing it you smuggle in love and it
plays the same role no no the love but
love is a an experience reality I mean
love love is its state of consciousness
it's a state of and I wouldn't
ultimately act
oh it's a it's a fact that one can
experience it or not well yeah there are
the fact that you can experience
something but their apparent you're
experiencing is there's also the thing
that you're experiencing as a fact well
know that there are facts about the the
the range of human experiences not even
just human just conscious experiences
that if we can build computers they can
feel loved and that's not inconceivable
and will either succeed in doing that or
not but consciousness admits of a range
of experiences and love is one of the
best on offer it's not the only one we
care about but it's the one that anchors
us to a positive commitment to the
well-being of other conscious systems
and but but the crucial thing is those
are far I agree no snow do you know what
it is it is a fact that
loving someone entails a really of it's
their their love and it's counterfeits
right there people can confuse you know
romantic you know attachment or lust
with love right so I've been and the
Buddhists are especially good at
differentiating these various states of
consciousness and and it's a II a this
this true pleasure mental pleasure in
the company of another that is colored
by a commitment to their well-being I
wanting them to be happy a wanting them
wanting to have their hopes realized a
nonzero-sum commitment or sense of your
entanglement with them and you can see
your failures to love me you can be with
people who you think you love you know
I'm with my best friend say and I just
find out something fantastic has
happened for him into let's say in his
career and I feel a moment of envy say
well then you see well okay what I just
how much do you love this person if the
for your first reaction to this
something good happening to them is you
feel poorer for it right
that's the Cain and Abel story exactly
so so this is these are all kinds of
defects you can witness in your own mind
and yes you pay enough attention to the
Nate to what it's like to be you the
full horror show of an almost you know
biblical unwinding of all possibility is
available you know and it's and you add
psychedelics to that cocktail and it
gets even more vivid alright so are we
do you think this is it but but the
painting attacks of you know the fact
these are facts about the human mind and
it is also factual to say that it is
possible to navigate in this space it is
possible to design institutions and and
social systems and ethical commitments
that help us navigate in the space it's
not that we all have to get up every
morning naked and try to rebuild
civilization and all of human wisdom for
ourselves each day you we inherit we
inherit the most useful tool the tools
you don't have to figure this all out
for yourself and my appeal to you is
that
what we should want to use all the best
tools available without hamstrung in
ourselves by this notion that certain
tools are must be the best for all time
or certain books must be read in on
every page with equals to diligence
because it that this book came from the
creator of the universe when we're
reading Marcus Aurelius if he gets
something catastrophic ly wrong on page
17 we say well what the hell he lived
2,000 years ago there's no way he knew
everything right and we turned the page
okay so we can't do that with the
Bible's the mythological representation
of that so there's an ancient idea a
very ancient idea that when you face the
void what you do is confront it and leap
into it and what you discover at the
bottom is a beast and inside that beast
you discover your father lying dead and
then you reanimate your father and you
bring him back to the surface and that's
the means of dealing with the void right
and so in his in essence in some sense
that's just what you said you said that
if we accept accept that again this
there's something confabulate ory about
that because you can do you I could
change the valence of virtually every
word you use there and it would also
sound profound and true I could I could
swap father for mother and I could swap
void from mountaintop and I and I could
it could be the same seemingly
archetypal journey and somebody makes a
it's not that easy sound like that's the
same damn easy I've done with a cookbook
but look if it's that easy then you can
write great novels great story so these
things can't be swapped out with these
well there is a reason that it's your
father that you rescue from the belly of
the beast and not your mother in those
sorts of situations you can't I give you
buddhism and hinduism that had that have
completely different iconographies and
mythologies and other different
variables but not at all it's like
languages but there's but there
they're not they're crucially opposite
in many of these cases I'm just saying
that this is this kind of reading
meaning into story is there's a reason
why it's not science because it's
because it is in some basic sense
unfalsifiable I there's nothing you and
I can do for the rest of our lives to be
sure that the mother isn't at the bottom
of that void and it's really the bottom
to develop a factual approach to the
analysis of literature
well yes on its own terms you can say
well it but that that extends to things
like it is a fact that Hamlet was the
Prince of Denmark and now I'm a in terms
of the writing of literature well yeah
but that you can make true and and false
claims or more and less plausible claims
about literature but that's what I'm
trying to do or it takes more its
effects on you but again but this is a
very different game than what most
religious people think is on offer well
look if you look at the domain of
science most scientists aren't very good
at what they do and if you look at the
domain of religious thinking most
religious thinking people aren't very
good at what they do but that doesn't
mean that the whole damn thing should be
thrown out there's relations of
religious revelation and and and and
wisdom but but there's that word obey
because a revelation if revelation is
something that we can all do you know
you me and Marcus Aurelia's right that
is a very different world than the world
that Muslims think they're living in but
you just said Sam that we have to go in
this is why I use the the going down
into the void to rescue your father
metaphor you just said that we have to
and you've said this before it I know
you believe it as well that we have to
go it back into the past and find the
the wisdom that can help guide us
because we don't have to do this as if
we're encountering everything for the
first time and that's exactly the idea
of going into the void to rescue your
father that's how bad in that is the
eternal age-old medication for the
confrontation of the void and you said
it yourself and so I don't know which it
is is like do we have to go into the
past to rescue what's best given the
understanding that there is something
there worth rescuing or not is it pure
rationality and nothing else moving
forward unconstrained by convention it
is it's it's
just again it's it's I want our
certainties and I think we all in every
other area of our lives we agree about
this effortlessly right if I'm
pretending to be certain of something
that you can sense I have no good reason
to be certain about you begin to
mistrust me in every area if it's in
business if it's in in sports or if I
told you I knew that France was gonna
win the World Cup and I was absolutely
sure and and and yet I magically didn't
bet any money on it I mean these are
these are conversations we can have that
everything else and yet on this topic of
religion people change the rules right
and I'm just arguing that the rules
should never the rules of by which we
dole out our our credence shouldn't
change and and if they don't it and
again it's we couldn't be misled by the
the duration of the past maybe this is
what this is the the the comparison of
something like Scientology to
Christianity is so invidious because we
can practically meet l ron Hubbard right
we've got film of him confabulating
about the galaxies the ruled by by
overlords whose names he magically knew
right we we see we see the man behind
the curtain we don't see that with the
Apostle Paul or anyone else who brought
us the the the quote real religions and
yet it's always just been human beings
doing this right and and and if you go
back far enough they were doing it in a
in a situation that was completely
uncontaminated by the kinds of concerns
we have as scientists and secular
rational people for evidence and
consistency and a knowledge of the past
I mean they had nothing even recorded it
had no mechanism by which to record
their observations no and I'm going drop
to you yes because festival I saw was
signs saying five minutes yes and I'm
very conscious of a number of things
apart from my own silence
and the we had a long session on love
just then and I refused to finish this
evening on such a positive note and I'd
like to turn that round we're all them
in agreement on certain aspects free
speech civilized discourse on the most
important matters and much more but
there's also I'm sure a lot we have in
common of what we just can't bear and I
just wanted to hand over to both of you
at some point to give an idea not of
your loves but of your present hates
that's Jordan
[Music]
[Applause]
hates
well I would say that I spent a lot of
time over the last thirty years trying
to understand the part of me that could
be deeply satisfied as an ostrich prison
guard and I would say that that part is
something that's worthy of hate and I
think the best way to overcome it is to
recognize it in yourself and to do
everything possible to constrain it and
that's what's given me an overwhelming
horror both of the nihilistic void and
the catastrophes of totalitarianism and
the reason that I've turned to the
degree that I have to the analysis of
religious traditions not losing my
scientific perspective in the meantime
is because I've done everything I could
to to extract out the wisdom necessary
to understand how to deal with that bit
of unredeemed evil that every bit of us
possess
well I would say that I hate unnecessary
suffering and especially my capacity for
it and I see so much of my time
conscious time moment a moment devoted
to this experience that should be
familiar to all of you which is it to be
captured by thoughts of the past or the
future which are which almost by
definition have a mediocrity so
transcendent that it's just a it it is
what makes human life just just pure
monotony and pettiness and
and everything that religion advertises
itself as a corrective - right
say that what I'm sensitive to is that
someone like SCI Utica - when he came to
this is Osama bin Laden's favorite
philosopher when he came to America in
the in the 50s he saw his hosts and
their neighbors spending all their time
you know bragging about how well mowed
their lawns were and and what just what
new Chevrolet as they had purchased and
he looked at all of this as just it's
just the quintessence of desecration and
lost opportunity and the lack of
profundity and for which for him the the
corrective obviously was Islam and half
of that is right it's possible to be
totally captivated by the wrong things
in this life and to make yourself not
it's so obviously being a guard at
Auschwitz with a clear conscience is the
extreme of the extremes of that
happiness all that or being a guard at
Auschwitz with happiness yes okay yeah
even worse still right so that's the
extreme case enter and to realize that
that is that that that job was not only
filled by psychopaths right that
psychologically normal people could
could be brought to that point
that's yeah I recognize that that's the
situation we're in but most of us live
our lives in a different place where
it's just mediocrity and pettiness and
and and needless anxiety and very dimly
we recognize the possibility of
overcoming that on a day-to-day basis
and you know honestly I think the
atheism the lack of belief the lack of
faith in an afterlife for instance the
lack of the lack of belief in the notion
that you get everything you want or may
get everything you want after you die
and helps Lalit's leads to greater depth
rather than to superficiality here it's
like when I kiss my daughter's goodnight
right it is with the understanding that
I may never see them again right it's
not with the assumption that if the roof
caves in where we'll all be reunited in
heaven along with our pets right which
is what both many people find consoling
about faith but that and and so what I
would say what I hate in myself and what
I hate in our culture is everything that
conspires to make the the preciousness
and and and sacredness of the present
moment difficult to realize and that's
that's what I as the tide against which
I keep slipping
iemon I'm not going to answer my own
question primarily because of the length
of the list and the knowledge of the
time but I would say that if there's one
thing I hate it's the fact that
conversations like this civil discussion
on the most important matters between
people who have enormous amounts in
common and have important disagreements
which engage with the past and which are
going to be facilitated for a long time
by knowledge of all the extraordinary
progress we're about to hit can take
place in an arena like this with an
audience like you who have all come out
and now set sat here for two hours and I
think it's at any rate from my point of
view one of the most positive things I
can imagine in the world at the moment
that an evening like this is happening
with an audience like you and unless
either of you want to say anything I
think on behalf of all of us I just like
to say what a thrill this is for us and
thank you to you and I hope that this is
an example of a constructive discussion
of a kind that might even at some point
catch on so thank you everyone please
put your hands together for sam Harris
Jordan Peterson and Douglas Murray hi